hi my name is Li syndrome today I'll
tell you a brief story about how I grew
up during Cultural Revolution dreaming
about becoming a writer but ended up
doing science for the last 24 years I
actually think my generation even though
we grew up during Cultural Revolution
was very fortunate well I think for
those of you who don't know Cultural
Revolution it was a pretty miserable
time for the country for many people
living in that era it continued for
twenty thirty years and there was a lot
of disruption for the country but as a
child growing up I think it was actually
quite enjoyable for example we really
didn't have many classes to take we I
remember studying math Chinese and
political science and really political
science count constitutes of studying
Chairman Mao's books and some other
slogans and propaganda because
scholastic achievements were not really
valued that much we really didn't have
much pressure and also there wasn't much
after-school activities we had a huge
amount of time on our hands we got to
really figure out ways to entertain
ourselves my parents both taught in
Tianjin University so he is the city
located in citroen province and if you
happen to like Chinese food you might
have tasted a very spicy lip loving
cetera and cuisine that's the city I
grew up in those days anybody who worked
for a university get to live on campus
and the I remember the campus we had
lived on was actually quite beautiful
there were large fish ponds that were
used to raise fish for everybody as food
there were also large medals and very
nice words wooded areas they one edge of
the campus actually is perched over a
cliff over
looking jolly River my apartment where
my parents lived in and my school were
happened to be actually on opposite end
of the campus so every day I had to walk
through the campus to go to school every
day after school I and my friends would
be roaming around the campus climbing
anything we could climb checking out all
the nooks and crannies of all the
buildings we really loved checking out
insects catching them and studying them
studying all the plants and flowers we
loved to catch tadpoles and take them
home put them in the bottle and raise
them to frog and let them go on the
medals I raised rabbits I raised
chickens I also learned how to plant
vegetables and sold them to my parents
to make some spending money but what I
liked the most was to read novels even
though we didn't have a whole lot of
variety in terms of novels we did get to
read those translated novels from the
old Russia or Soviet Union we were
actually very lucky those novels were
quite amazing really outstanding
literature I had from those readings I
had always wanted to become a writer
to write those exciting and very
touching novels that life that very
idyllic life suddenly came to an end
with the end of the Cultural Revolution
of course it's great the Cultural
Revolution has ended and everybody was
really happy especially our parents
because our age group still had two to
three years to make some make up some
education gaps and another very
important thing that's really fortunate
for us was that we finally got the
opportunity to go to university based on
our test scores instead of based on our
births class suddenly the daily heavy
studying homework and quizzes returned
with vengeance and without warning
suddenly also test scores become the
most important thing and you know every
test your scores along with everybody
else
the class is posted on the wall and you
get to see exactly where you wrapped and
the idea was to encourage everybody to
study harder but it was actually very
hard very competitive especially for my
class group because all the kids are
very bright they came from the best they
came as the best of their class in
schools throughout the city for me I
really never got used to that intensity
of studying also I really was very
attracted to read a lot of new novels
that had become available after Cultural
Revolution so often times I would hit
the novels in my drawer to read them
while I was supposed to be doing problem
sets luckily there was only about two
years and I managed to be able to stay
in the middle of the pack in my class
and also I managed to get into a
university even though my parents
weren't particularly happy that I was
never on the top of my class or getting
into a universe getting into the best
university in China such as Beijing or
Shanghai University I did get into a
university so they didn't give me too
much trouble after about 12 hours
negotiation in terms of what I would
major my parents and I made a concession
that I would major in biology so I went
to citron university majored in biology
but after the after the university after
four years I again went against my
parents wishes to not continue my
education in graduate school I went to
work as a teaching assistant in the
southwestern Agricultural University
which is local located in the rural
parts of Tanjung my idea was every day
after work I will be able to have enough
time to really start writing but after a
year I realized actually to write the
stories as good as those that had
touched me so deeply was very very
difficult and since life was quite
boring because the university is
localized located in basically in the
countryside there wasn't much to do
after work I got increasingly Restless
and we
we want to change my life and my parents
really my parents saw the opportunity to
finally help me to get rid of my dream
of becoming a writer my dad told me okay
you are frustrated with your writing why
don't you go abroad to study and to see
the world
perhaps after your studying after
traveling and seeing the world then
you'll have some interesting stories to
write about I actually didn't like the
idea about going abroad to study biology
but that was my only option I think what
really got me going was to the the idea
of going abroad to see the world so
that's how I managed to come to America
and I have been in this country for 24
years and I have been doing a biological
research ever since it is actually the
logic of genetic screens that attracted
me to join doctor Burrell oakley's lab
at the University at the Ohio State
University in Burroughs lab I studied
microtubules and cell division I
continued the study of cell division in
dr. Bruce Alberts and dr. Tim Mitchell
sands lab in San Francisco where I have
actually learned how to do biochemistry
how to use in vitro assays to study cell
division so I have so far studied cell
division for 24 years about five years
ago our studies of cell division has had
inspired us to initiate a new research
angle in my lab that is to try to
understand whether cytoskeleton such as
microtubules could influence chromatin
organization within the nucleus during
the development and disease state this
new research direction has been quite
difficult because we had to learn a lot
of new techniques and a lot of new areas
of biology that weren't familiar to us
and there was definitely times that I
wondered whether had made a huge career
mistake by not focusing on cell division
or studying something I knew how to
study that I had expertise but after
thinking back and forth my conclusion
had always been I would never be able to
pass up the up
unity to study something that really
inspires me to me doing research
especially biological research is like
making journeys you can choose to take a
well-traveled Road that kind of road is
safer it will probably get you to your
destination faster you'll be more
productive but if you really get
inspired and you have some ideas those
ideas could lead to bigger discoveries
as scientist you have the opportunity to
choose the less traveled Road to explore
you may not be appreciated for quite a
while but your ideas your inspiration
should keep you going for quite a while
despite the difficulties and if you in
the end succeed to make some exciting
discoveries you'll become the happiest
and most content person in the world I
think this is probably the reason why
whenever you ask cyan't a scientist
whether they like their job they will
always tell you this is the exciting
career I think that's also the reason
why I have been doing science for 25
years
you